dans ce quartier dévasté au milieu des
bâtiments toujours en flammes un
habitant filmé ces images
après plusieurs semaines passées sous
les bombes ils se préparent à quitter
marioupol avec quelques valises et sa
famille
voici mes enfants sur la masia n'ya
héros de jk on est réveillé depuis 5
heures ce qu'on a fait nos valises et on
espère partir ce qu'on a vécu tu ne le
souhaite à personne
les bus que c'est civiles espèrent les
voici prise en photo sur la route de
berne ce qu une cinquantaine d'autocars
et de camions humanitaires sont attendus
pour débuté l'évacuation
mais les familles sont souvent caché
depuis plusieurs semaines pour échapper
aux bombes l'un des enjeux sera de
trouver et prévenir tous ceux qui
veulent partir
nous estimons que 150 mille civils sont
toujours en marioupol
mais ces personnes vivent comme des
souris sous la terre dans les abris anti
bombes dans les espaces sous la terre
chacun fait de son mieux pour survivre
[Musique]
17 bus ont quitté apport est déjà en
direction de berdsk et attendent
toujours de rejoindre marioupol ce
dernier tronçon où des combats sont
toujours en cours et particulièrement
dangereux
les équipes de la croix-rouge volts
aller très vite
les gens sont dans la ville sans accès à
l'eau à la nourriture à l'aide
humanitaire et donc il est extrêmement
important que cette opération puisse
avoir lieu une preview seule condition
capitale pour que l'évacuation ait lieu
que le cessez le feu soit bel et bien
respecté